Sackhoff of newsweek mr. Isikoff thanks
for being here this morning
good morning this is your report from
this week's Newsweek it looks like you
were the first journalist to have a look
at this report or to write on it yeah
it's a big report so this I think
there's gonna be a lot to write about
when we finally get the document in just
a couple hours but I focused there on I
think what is going to get some of the
most attention which is the failings of
the FBI especially in the San Diego area
in fact the saga of the intelligence
lapses prior to 9/11 involves a lot of
different players a lot of different
agencies failures but it revolves mostly
around two of the hijackers Kali Talmud
are in Waffle House me who flew into the
United States from a al Qaeda terrorist
summit in Malaysia in January 2000 they
settled into the San Diego area and have
numerous contacts with people who were
known to the FBI they live in the house
of an FBI informant it turns out as the
report will make clear there was an
abundance of information about these two
individuals within the US intelligence
community in fact the CIA knew about
them coming to the United States never
passed that along to the FBI the FBI had
a lot of leads about the some of the
individuals who they were coming into
contact with and the report is going to
criticize both the CIA for not passing
along the information that it had and
the FBI for not aggressively
investigating many of the Terrorism
leads in the San Diego area that might
have led them to these two hijackers
we're gonna continue taking your calls
on the 9/11 intelligence report the
numbers are on the screen if you tend to
agree with President Bush 202 585 3880
if you tend to disagree with President
Bush 202 580 538 81 yesterday the
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee was on this program Senator
Pat Roberts here's what he had to say
let me ask you about this report that is
expected to come out tomorrow its
previewed in this week's Newsweek
magazine quote the FBI blue repeated
chances to uncover the 9/11 plot because
it failed to aggressively investigate
evidence that al Qaeda's presidents in
the US especially
in the san diego area where two of the
hijackers were living according to this
congressional report set for release
this week and again it's coming out
tomorrow
a 900 page document that's essentially
correct there were many egregious errors
in hindsight 2020 I was a member of that
investigation bottom line is I don't
think there's anything that the FBI CA
could have done into the circumstances
to prevent the attack was there anything
have you heard well I mean is no I mean
there is no smoking gun there is no
specific piece of information that that
they had in their possession that told
them there was going to be an attack on
September 11th against the World Trade
Center and the and the Pentagon but
there were a lot of missed opportunities
that could have led them to these two
hijackers those two hijackers had then
you know proceeded to interact with
something like eight or nine others so
had the FBI been surveilling them had
they been monitoring them had they had
national security warrants to tap their
phones and track what they were doing
there is a reasonable chance that they
might have come across the plot if all
the pieces had been put together now
again that's hindsight and it's always
easier to say in hindsight but it but
but the report is important for a number
of reasons it does highlight a lot of
the problems in communication sharing in
the use of intelligence that was clearly
present in the in the days before
September 11th and led to what in its
totality was obviously the most massive
intelligence failure since Pearl Harbor
well continue talking with Michael
Isikoff for the next half hour and take
your calls Clinton Iowa you're first up
good morning I wanted to talk to
congressman LaHood is gone just go ahead
make my statements anyway go ahead sir
first of all that this report coming out
won't be believed unless there's like
independent commission set up and I'm
not one of the political ones like in
the last administration and second of
all mr. LaHood made a statement that it
was like the Clinton administration that
pulled the funding for the FBI
the CIA where does this go back and
investigate the Clinton administration
well investigate the Clinton
ministration per se but it certainly
goes back many years and covers a period
of time when the Clinton ministration
was in charge so that's certainly case
there on the caller's point there is a
Independent Commission that is following
up on the the evidence in this report
and it is working for a.m. we'll have a
more complete report covering a broader
range of areas this focuses on the
intelligence failures the independent
commission's report will include that
and include a lot of material and report
that's did a release next spring I think
in May next call for Michael Isikoff
Liberty Texas good morning mr. Isikoff I
just like to praise your work we seem to
be getting a lot of beards on the
program and you're a rarity in that you
actually have some some articulate ideas
to express I would just like to say that
this game as far as pointing the finger
at the Clinton administration is
preposterous where the true issue it
seems to be that because the Republicans
offer more funding to management of the
intelligence services that they seem to
come down on that side and that the
greatest travesty of all were the
thousands of intelligence hours we're
hearing a lot about squandered resources
that the resources were there the
information was there but the FBI and
these intelligence services were
distracted doing said squirrel assinged
as investigating Monica Lewinsky the
greatest travesty of all is the fact
that these people are supposed to be
professionals they have a job beyond
politics and that they are supposed to
be protecting people 24 hours a day 365
days of the year mr. Isikoff well there
are a lot of things you can say about
that obviously first of all decisions
about what the FBI should focus its
resources on our decisions made by
ultimately prosecutors
in the Justice Department or independent
counsels in some cases but I I mean I
think the broader issue is the attention
that was devoted to the terrorist threat
given you know Al Qaeda's clear presence
in Afghanistan the thought was from bin
Laden saying we are out to kill
Americans the the plotting that was
going on that was known to the
intelligence community were the proper
resources devoted to that threat over
many years and I think the report is
going to suggest that insufficient well
though a lot of people were talking
about it a lot of people recognize the
threat it didn't the the message didn't
go down to the troops in the field
there's a common thread in all the
articles on this report and starting
with yours Wall Street Journal New York
Times Philadelphia Inquirer today
talking about the fact that the Saudi
there's 28 pages missing or being
deleted from the public report because
it deals with Saudi Arabia right that is
going to be probably the biggest
political fallout from this the the
deleted 28 page section which is I think
ambiguously referred to or vaguely
referred to as the role of foreign
governments that's primarily the Saudis
but as we report in the piece this week
there's there there are sort of
tantalizing pieces of evidence that's
going to be included in the in other
sections of the report one involves some
of that involves the command by the name
of Omar all by you me it was a key
associate of these two hijackers in San
Diego who the report suggests may have
been a Saudi government agent the man in
fact had before he meets the hijackers
and when they fly into the country in
Los Angeles he goes to a closed-door
meeting at the Saudi consulate in Los
Angeles and then goes directly to a
restaurant where the hijackers appear he
meets them he takes them to San Diego he
puts them up in an apartment he fronts
them money to help pay their rent and
facilitates their settling into the
United States and the report is going to
raise a lot of questions about who by
you me was and who he was working for
and and and ultimately whether that does
it's going to raise questions about
his connections to Saudi Arabia the FBI
I should point out says that they did
fully investigate by you me and did not
find that he provided material support
to the hijackers I think there's gonna
be some questioning of that today and
you report that Mister by Yumi is back
at Saudi Arabia he is back in Saudi
Arabia living openly as I understand it
is unclear whether there was any
continued investigative interest by the
FBI and him Prince Bandar or the Saudi
ambassadors the United States did put
out a statement yesterday vehemently
denying that he was a Saudi government
agent but again just take that one
incident I described in the in the piece
this meeting at the Saudi consulate I
think one thing I'm going to be looking
for in the report is to see whether
whether the FBI pursued that did they
questioned people in the Saudi consulate
about why by you me was there and what
his business would the Saudi consulate
was you know I don't know if it's gonna
be in the public report or not we'll see
in a few hours and I should note that we
called the Saudi embassy repeatedly
yesterday and got no response to our
request for a short interview Powerton
Virginia you're on the air good morning
Virginia you're on the air this is this
is just really up answer to me and I am
just in sense as an American that this
28 pages is being redacted in fact I
think anybody could do a Google search
and find that there's 30 years of
continuing and growing increasingly
awful terrorist attacks and since the
9/11 bombing there's been the Bamiyan
Valley there's been the ships in Yemen I
mean this really bothers me and I want
to know was this with our stock market
stock market manipulated Michael Isikoff
the stock market manipulation question
was something that came up early on it
was not an area that was pursued by this
the congressional committees I know it
is the people at the SEC have been have
taken a look at that and it's on the
radar screen of the rate of
dependent Commission as far as I know no
credible evidence has developed that
suggests there was any connection
between sales of stocks prior to
September 11th and the attacks
themselves oka Raton Florida good
morning you're on the air you know 2020
is hindsight and just like the corporate
corporation it started when Clinton was
in office all this stuff was starting
when Clinton was in the office and a lot
more even before when Reagan was in on
everything
ever since the grandfather of terrorism
Arafat started doing the hijackings it
has escalated into this I believe that
the Islamic people hold grudges for a
long long time and they're they're
trying to get back into the 700 AD when
they had most of the world controlled
and they're very patient people their
population is growing or they're
spreading into every nation every
country in the world
France is 30 percent a lot of the
countries are afraid to do anything
because of that amount of people in
their country and I you know the blame
game I don't think it should be a blame
game mr. Isikoff
I don't really have much to say it was
rather overly broad brush the caller was
painting them Glenn Simpson and David
Rogers right this morning The Wall
Street Journal I want to get your
reaction to this if if this is what you
found also the White House has refused
repeated requests from the intelligence
panel to turn over the president's
briefing materials for August 6th 2001
citing national security a footnote in
the report merely summarizes an account
of the briefing that national security
adviser Condoleezza Rice gave it a news
conference last year
yeah those those presidential Daily
Brief s-- the intelligence briefs of the
president's gets those are those are a
very contentious issue the White House
takes a very hard line that the
president's daily intelligence briefing
that could not be covered by executive
privilege that could not be shared with
Congress or shouldn't be shared with
Congress the SAC
institutional position that I think all
white houses would probably take
certainly have taken in the past yet it
is key to understanding of of how the
warnings of the al-qaeda threat were
being handled within the within the
government at that time as is now
well-known there were a lot of alarm
bells going off in the summer of 2001 in
fact there's an earlier intelligence
brief in July that was quoted in during
one of the public hearings
that's quite explicitly warns that
there's going to be a spectacular attack
by al Qaeda in the coming weeks the
attack will come without warning mass
casualties could result it's pretty
alarming language yet there's a lot of
uncertainty about when this was
presented the administration refused to
declassify exactly who got that briefing
and what and then you know the obvious
follow-up is what did you do after it
this briefing referred to in the Glenn
Simpson piece is August six briefing for
Condoleezza Rice I believe it took place
at the presidential ranch in Crawford
again it was a discussion of the al
Qaeda threat at that moment the and
there was apparently discussion about
the use of airplanes as weapons exactly
what was said we're not going to find
out because of the White House position
the more important issue it seems to me
is what flowed from that and what did
people do when getting this intelligence
and I think this is where there is at
least some potential vulnerability to
the Bush White House next call for
Michael Isikoff comes from Sullivan
County New York good morning good
morning and as always thank you for
c-span number one I'd like to disagree
with prior caller who said that no blame
should be put on the Clinton
administration the Clinton
administration on its watch we had the
bombings in Africa by al Qaeda
and there should have been more
coordination between the FBI and the CIA
during the Clinton administration
and there was not and so the Clinton
administration deserves a great deal of
the blame for what happened he just was
not as dick Maher as as pointed out
numerous times he just was not
interested in foreign threats to the
United States that's number one number
two another caller prior said that well
he implied we need a new immigration
policy regarding immigration
to this country from the Arab world
there are just too many in this country
and they are a threat to the United
States mr. Isikoff plenty of blame to go
around are there any solutions offered
in this room first of all how much of
the 900 pages have you had access to
I've had portions read to me and I've
had portions described to me but 900
pages is a lot of pages so there's a lot
I'm gonna be looking for did any did
anyone read or did you have described to
you any solutions or proposed well there
were yeah there was a public summary
that was put out last I think was
December from the committees that gave
their findings and recommendations and
that was most of them were public back
in December and it it covered some of
the obvious obvious areas about greater
information sharing and it raised the
question of restructuring the FBI and of
course a lot of those director Muller
has tried to initiate a lot of these
himself putting much more focus on
counterterrorism and elevating
counterterrorism within the FBI to put
you know certainly its number-one
priority by far next call Cambridge
Illinois good morning good morning mr.
Isikoff morning Mike and my concern
rests with the Office of Special plans
run run by the white dis administration
by a man by the name of Abram solski and
and something like a sister you
or a unit run out of Israel by Errol's
Ariel sharone that's separate and
distinct from their own intelligence
unit which forward intelligence reports
to the office of special plans you know
anything about that well I certainly
know about the office of special plans a
lot of attention has been given to that
particularly in the in the context of
the war on Iraq they were focusing a lot
this is a pentagon Intelligence Unit
that was set up and did spend a lot of
time developing intelligence that
related to related to Iraq it's been
controversial some of its some of its
conclusions differ from those of the US
intelligence other US intelligence
agencies I'm not sure it's this to the
9/11 report because I don't believe it
existed until after September 11th
Michael Isikoff has been with Newsweek
since 1994 as an investigative
correspondent covered President
Clinton's impeachment also is an author
of a book uncovering Clinton a
reporter's story because of your
position as an investigative
correspondent are you sniffing or
smelling any scandal with this
intelligence report Wow scandal is a
term that can be interpreted in a lot of
different ways I mean I mean not
corruption but I think some people will
find people get quite passionate about
these subjects we'll find some of the
missed opportunities and failings that
will be identified in the report as
scandalous
but perhaps not in the sense of in which
others might look at it Berkeley
California good morning hello good
morning I had a quick question it's not
on one side of the other I just was
wondering if you see any potential for
our government in this country advancing
or progressing in the absence of
partisan centrifuge it just kind of
seems to me as Johnny citizen that this
phenomenon is central to what's kind of
like hindering progress and sort of
keeping our Rev of democracy that we
currently are existing with in this
state of sort of chasing its tail around
I'm not sure what he meant but I mean if
I well I think you're gonna see some
partisanship as you inevitably do in
Washington with the report today Senator
Bob Graham is running for president
United States he's gonna be one of the
participants in the press conference
this afternoon because he was one of
those who oversaw the inquiry he's very
big on the on the role which is sort of
shorthand for the Saudi role he's been
hitting that quite hard for some time
and is seeking to make it a political
issue Porter Goss who's the House
Republican chairman of the Intelligence
Committee has worked with Senator Graham
on a lot of these issues but obviously
is not going to cast point fingers at
the bush White House in the way that I
think you'll see senator Graham do today
two related emails this is from Joel
weight of DC what federal laws or
restrictions hindered or forbid the
Intelligence Sharing within the various
agencies and from newton massachusetts
agents did not have legal access to
arrested terrorist computers will they
now be allowed easier access a couple of
actually that first question is is a
very pertinent one and it also relates
to I think the second one there was if
you have to identify the biggest barrier
to information sharing that could have
the kind of information sharing that
might have led US intelligence and law
enforcement to the 9/11 plot it's this
concept that was known as the wall which
is that information gleaned by the
intelligence community could not be
shared with the law enforcement
community and this stemmed from laws
passed by Congress but also
interpretations of those laws that were
enacted primarily during the under the
Reno Justice Department in which they
were very strict guidelines that were
imposed to ensure that that kind of
information sharing did not take place
because there were concerns about an
abuse of civil liberties it's much
easier to get information for the
intelligence community
get information they can get these
secret national security warrants FISA
warrants that are done issued by a
secret court lower standard and the
concern was that you get a lot of that
you get a lot of these warrants you pick
up a lot of information about people
inside the United States that doesn't
get the normal kind of judicial scrutiny
to ensure that there's not abuses going
on and then you share that with if you
shared that with law enforcement people
you could have criminal investigations
people being prosecuted in ways that
that that that violated the kind of
constitutional rights that the the
courts have said every citizen is
entitled to so you did have this concept
of the wall and but the result the
unfortunate result of that is that there
was information within the hands of the
US government about terrorists activity
that was not being shared with the law
enforcement people who could go out and
do something about it and disrupt the
activity and arrest the perpetrators
that issue has been addressed it was
addressed in the Patriot Act there was
also a very crucial US Court of Appeals
ruling that said that the FBI and
Justice Department were misinterpreting
the law and putting too high a standard
on information sharing so the
combination of that is there is a lot
more of that that goes on it goes on
routinely now and that there is it is
volumes of information that has been
gleaned and is being gleaned by the
intelligence community that is given
instantly to law enforcement agents now
and what about the terrorists computers
well that was the I think what that's
refers to is the Mousawi case where was
how he gets picked up Zacharias Mossad
gets picked up in Minneapolis and in in
August August 16th the FBI agents they
are very suspicious of him he has all
the earmarks of being a terrorist he was
taking these flight school training
didn't seem to be interested in terribly
much in in landing an airplane just in
steering it I clearly had these radical
Islamic views and and connections going
back they wanted to crack into his
laptop into his computer but they needed
a they felt they needed a FISA warrant
one of these national security
intelligence warrants the FBI wouldn't
allow them to get it because they didn't
feel that there was sufficient predicate
for them to get it so therefore the
information they could not get into the
computer now whether that would have led
its it's not at all clear that that
would have led them to anything in the
9/11 plot but it might have generated a
great deal of more interest in in in who
Mousawi was associated with where he
came from and if put together with other
information possibly maybe could have
made a difference next call Paso Robles
California good morning California will
move on to Conyers Georgia Conyers
Georgia you're on the air yeah in
Conyers Georgia the group of people I
hang around with they're Democrats and
Republicans and we've been discussing
enough that you know not sharing of
information is one of the greatest
things that hurt our country but how
much does that compare to the torricelli
bill were where we couldn't put people
in into these groups that had any kind
of shady character and also the
underlying saying how are we handling
the the teaching of the Mohave uh you
know the the teaching of hating American
is when countries it's tough are we
making any kind of dent in that because
until we make a dent in that and then
people come over and join our
institutions to learn how to kill us
really and then go back you know there's
a lot of things that we need to be
working on two things the reference to
the Torricelli
bill is another example of where
restrictions that were imposed during
the 90s to address what seemed to be
very legitimate concerns at the time did
have unintended consequences that
contributed to the intelligence failures
of 9/11 in that case the concern was the
CIA having informants using assets
overseas who had
who had records of human rights abuses
who were thugs who were murderers that
we were essentially getting in bed with
a lot of unsavory people and so
restrictions were put on who the CIA
could use as an asset overseas the
concerns seem legitimate at the time
given some of the abuses that had taken
place especially in Central America
which I think Torricelli was as focused
on but one result was too sharply curb
the CIA's ability to recruit new assets
because let's face it when you're
dealing with you know thugs thuggish
organ and criminal organizations such as
al-qaeda you're not likely to find you
know pure pristine people who are going
to be able to penetrate it but one
conclusion and the report is that the
CIA essentially didn't have any human
assets inside the al-qaeda certainly
inside al-qaeda leadership and that is a
big failing because some people think
the only way you could really get good
Intel is to penetrate an organization
and have spies inside who can tell you
what its leaders are talking about and
thinking about we didn't have that we
have about five minutes left with
Michael Isikoff he's going to go up to
the Capitol at get the report at 8:30 I
believe New York City you're on the air
good morning good morning how you doing
Calista I just want to just comment on
this was it by you me the gentleman by
you me in Saudi Arabia you know I'm used
to work in Saudi Arabia and I find that
well even when I was working there that
getting anything dealing with see see
like the officers and stuff that that
are there it is very very difficult as
an American dealing with their laws and
what have you
now but you but you me came to the
United States and and paid the rent for
these for the apartments for these
gentlemen who were in San Diego is there
any way do you know that they could have
extradited him back to the United States
to face questioning on this
personally I know it's very very
difficult because for instance it's
basically a closed society so how could
the United States government extradite
them back so they could question it
personally number one and number two is
real quick I disagree with that caller
who called and talked about they need to
close down the borders to to Muslims and
what have you
I disagree totally with that because you
need people you need to understand the
way they think you need to understand
their culture you need to understand
what they're thinking so that way we can
we can have a clearer of a clearer
picture I on the question of extraditing
by you me the problem is to x-ray at
somebody you have to criminally charge
them and the FBI is said it doesn't have
sufficient evidence to charge by you me
with a crime he was picked up he left
the United States prior to 9/11 in July
of 2001 actually went to England was
living in Birmingham and was picked up
by New Scotland Yard after September
11th and questioned quite a bit by New
Scotland Yard with the cooperation of
the FBI and the conclusion then this was
relatively early on October 2001 is that
they although there was a lot of
suspicious circumstantial evidence they
couldn't find direct evidence that he
had provided material support knowing
material support for the for the
hijackers there some people have looked
at what was available to the FBI and the
handling of by you me and say that that
people were being held as material
witnesses with a lot less evidence than
they had on by you me one of the
problems here is that he was in Britain
he wasn't in the United States and it
was really the Brits call as to whether
or not he was should be let go he was
let go he is back in Saudi Arabia at
that point given that there's no
criminal charge that he's facing in the
United States it becomes a matter of
working with the Saudis to try to get
access to him the south prince bandar
said yesterday that he was questioned in
Saudi Arabia by their own
interior ministry officials and they
didn't find any evidence that he was
working with the terrorists now if the
some of the suggestions in the report
are correct then that he had some ties
to the Saudi government that could
explain the Saudis reticence about
aggressively pursuing mr. by you me
what's been the Saudi cooperation with
you as a journalist with me as a
journalist well I don't they are not
known for their great cooperation with
journalists I mean Prince Bandar is a
very press savvy guy and does pick
favorite reporters usually very
prominent ones in the United States who
he likes to talk to and can be a great
source of information for about a lot of
political gossip in Washington the guy's
got amazing access to the White House on
the other hand he is quite an
interesting character in his own right
and whether he's being fully candid
especially about his own government and
his own role on things is is another
question time for one more call with
Michael Isikoff of Dulce New Mexico good
morning hi I just want to respond to a
earlier call and I don't want to speak
for the earlier caller but the caller
was talking about partisan ideas or
partisanship and I guess my question is
if the goal the investigation is to find
ways to more efficiently handle these
types of threats isn't that type of
bigger picture somehow Sullivan in other
words if there is too powerful I mean
you're talking constantly about
specifics and if there's two powerful
entities that are constantly countering
the opposition just for the case of
countering the opposition isn't that in
terms of the structure of the whole
picture completely unproductive in other
words one there a point where Clinton
himself wanted to go after in some of
the Latin and a few years ago and was
stopped by Republicans sort of not
wanting him to do that and sort of
countering him for probably no other
reason than just Democrats right now
work I don't think anybody would stop
from going after bin Laden there was a
question to whether the political
climate in the United States at the time
would have led to public support for a
huge military effort in Afghanistan in a
foreign country at that time especially
if there wasn't a full public
appreciation for what was known by the
intelligence community about the threat
that bin Laden imposed on the
partisanship question I mean my sense
from watching a lot of these public
hearings is that the intelligence
community's the the leadership of the
intelligence committees I by Capitol
Hill standards is probably less partisan
than then than many others I happen to
be sitting in briefly during the
Judiciary Committee yesterday when they
were debating judge Pryor because I was
waiting for FBI director Muller to
testify and you know the level of
partisans partisanship there and on that
issue far exceeds anything you see in
the oversight of the intelligence
committees but all that said I think
you're gonna see some partisan spinning
going on after the report is is publicly
released this afternoon what will you be
looking for in the report well I'm gonna
be looking for a lot of the details that
I've written about how it's handled the
wording I'm gonna be obviously also
looking I'm told this is gonna be
interesting because the report you'll be
able to see in the report exactly what
was what you'll see the context of the
deletions in other words they left the
report you know you'll have the page
there and then you'll see blacked out
portions so you'll you'll be able to
sort of get a handle on the kinds of
material that's being deleted and I
think that's gonna raise you know as
many questions as some of the stuff
that's going to be in the report itself
Michael Isikoff is with Newsweek
magazine and we appreciate your being
here I understand you've got a chat
tomorrow and Newsweek oh yes at noon on
our website Newsweek com I'll be
answering questions about the about the
report so you can log on and far away
then you've got 900 pages to read
between now and then cuz I do indeed
thank you joining us now on the phone is
Robert Baer he's a former CIA field
officer he's also the author of the book
see no evil and a reason
Atlantic Monthly cover story on Saudi
Arabia mr. bear good morning good
morning thanks for joining us 28 pages
of this is going to be deleted from the
public report and it deals with Saudi
Arabia what's your reaction to that I
think that's unfortunate because there's
a lot of suspicions about the Saudi role
we know that every turn in this plot of
9/11 is a Saudi involved not just the
intelligent agent intelligence agents in
California and I think that people want
to know what is the Saudi connection by
blacking it out they're gonna really
start to wonder I in The Wall Street
Journal this morning it reports that one
section that survived that will be in
the report describes Saudi assistance to
some of the 19 hijackers among the new
information his allegations that funds
from Saudi businessman reached the
hijackers through intermediaries I think
that's absolutely true that the group in
Germany which ought to belong and had
Saudi partners in Hamburg and more than
there's more than two of them we don't
know who those people are we don't know
who the people are that supported the
mosque in San Diego where the two
hijackers arrived in 2000 January
there's a lot more questions than
answers when it comes to the Saudi role
and with regard to the Saudis how what's
their support like in the Bush
administration I think they're supports
very good the Bush administration as the
previous administration have looked
Saudi Arabia as an ally it's been
classified as an ally the Central
Intelligence Agency never looked at it
as an enemy
at least until September 11th and it's
hard for people to get over the fact
that there are serious problems in the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia such as strong
support for bin Laden as one CIA
official described it there are a lot of
bin Laden supporters embedded in the
Saudi regime and it's going to be an
uphill struggle for the Saudi royal
family to root them out well how was how
was the Saudi royal family treated them
thus far I think they were as surprised
as we were about September 11th and a
lot of
at least and they had just been
complacent about the fundamentally
Robert Baer is former CIA field officer
he's off all also the author of the book
see no evil thanks for joining us this
morning thanks for having me we're gonna
continue taking your calls on the 9/11
intelligence report due out by Congress
the House Senate Intelligence Committee
held 13 meetings closed to the public
and nine public meetings since they
started this in February 2002 they
released a public summary in December of
2002 and today at 8:30 a.m. the full
900-page congressional intelligence
report on 9/11 will be released to the
public and on the web as soon as we get
that web address we'll make sure to get
it to you so that you can find it also
burn wood Wisconsin good morning uh
hello
thank you for c-span I had seen a
documentary by Alex Jones that was
called the road to tyranny it mentioned
that two months prior to 9/11 President
George W Bush had signed a presidential
decision directive W 199 I and this
actually prevented them from arresting
any of the al-qaeda suspects
if the FBI agents or defense
intelligence officers did they
themselves could be arrested for
national security implications I just
wondered if anyone else heard about this
or if any other information had come out
about it let's see if any of our callers
have heard anything about that joining
us in a few minutes will be congressman
Silvestre Reyes he is a Democrat of
Texas and a member of the House
Intelligence Committee we'll continue
our conversation on this issue with him
Red Bank New Jersey you're on the air
good morning good morning it amazes me
that President Bush was in the White
House
a year and a half and how organizations
could get so degraded in a year and a
half and have not known anything prior
to that and one of the things I worked
in a communications business and people
still ask me
why they broke up AT&T and my answer is
it was run so efficiently that it was an
embarrassment to the government Cleo
Michigan what are your thoughts on the
9/11 congressional investigation well I
have had questions since the moment it
happened I have a May 14th article of
that year from Louis Freeh giving in an
interview to Elsa Walsh and he says in
this article that he wants to go on
record and he has memos to cover him
because of things that happen during his
administration when President Clinton
appointed him his very speech said Louis
Freeh was to be in charge of seeking out
the terrorists and if you go back you'll
find that speech but what's interesting
about Louis Freeh and I find nothing
comes up about Louie free he left office
in June before 911 spanned our Prince
Abdullah with the ex President Bush to
try to maneuver President Clinton now he
would not he did not talk to Clinton for
the for a year for four years while
Clinton was in the White House he was
dealing with prince Bandar and Prince
Abdullah where is Louis Freeh an
ex-president Bush since President Bush
was in that quadrant of people trying to
influence policy they were trying to
keep the Saudi investigation from
occurring to do with the Khobar towers
and they were trying to divert the
attention to one of the other countries
over there and cause Clinton to go to
war then there is here's a little bit
from The Wall Street Journal this
morning about Louis Freeh not exactly
what you were talking about but a couple
of paragraphs not every attempt to block
information succeed
in one episode two people familiar with
the report said administration officials
sought to limit the testimony of seven
or eight federal bureau of investigation
officials critical of Saudi Arabia's
cooperation which law enforcement law
enforcement officials long have
described privately as half-hearted and
woefully inadequate
there was no similar interference toward
testimony by former FBI director Louis
Freeh whose account of the Saudi role
was more positive and just just for
clarification with regard to the report
being released at 8:30 a.m. this morning
it is being released to the press at
8:30 however it is embargoed until 2
p.m. this afternoon when the four
principals from the 2002 House and
Senate intelligence committees hold
their press conference Bob Graham Nancy
Pelosi Porter Goss and Pat Roberts and
there is a 9 a.m. background briefing
just for the press this morning but we
will
we cannot if we get it before 9 o'clock
which we think we will we can show it to
you but we can't read anything from it
until 2 p.m. it's embargoed and at 2
p.m. you can go to c-span or get will be
linked to our web site at 2:00 p.m. this
afternoon Lathrop California you're on
the air yes this I'm just seeing a lot
of posturing and finger pointing going
on and it is well known thing on
Judicial Watch that FBI agents right
after 9/11 were blocked from going after
al-qaeda and simply put the Carlyle
Group biggest investors the bin Laden
family and the Bush family I mean that
should say it all to Americans about
what's really going on who are the
terrorists involved in our government
itself thank you and coming up at 9:00
o'clock this morning we'll be joined
we're going to be switching topics from
9:00 to 10:00
Jerry Jennings will be